right as moles which hyung continues you
might remember the great one Mark Levin
right here on this show last summer
explaining the DOJ policy that says a
sitting president cannot be indicted
this is something the media kind of
forgets take a look it's been the
position of the United States Department
of Justice under Republicans and
Democrats in a 1973 memorandum and an
October memorandum under the Clinton
administration that you must not cannot
indict these sitting president not that
this president would be that's not my
point as a matter of constitutional
interpretation for 44 years that's been
the position of the Department of
Justice we've had law professors
homeless people would be law professors
all over TV and radio talking about
obstruction of justice we've had media
types talking about it we've had members
of Congress talking about it it doesn't
matter the official position of the
Justice Department is we don't charge a
city president with a crime now Mark
reiterated that point on this show just
a few weeks ago you may remember a
sitting president Amin ability to
indictment in criminal prosecution the
indictment or criminal prosecution of a
sitting president would
unconstitutionally undermine the
capacity of the executive branch to
perform its constitutionally assigned
functions page after page after page
saying a sitting United States president
cannot be indicted
now my question is this did they issue
another memo over there at the Justice
Department reversing these two memos
during the Nixon administration and the
Clinton administration no he joins us
herself with reaction the host of CR
TV's Levin TV those of life liberty and
Levin the number one show Sunday nights
10:00 Eastern right here on the Fox News
Channel I call them the great one Mark
Levin I wanted to play that again
because as usual on legal matters you're
ahead of the curve you are a
constitutional attorney and our lazy
overpaid liberal activists that call
themselves journalists are wrong like
99% of the time so I want to go through
this legally tonight and give you the
opportunity
explain it to them yet again alright
Sean this is not me speaking this is the
Department of Justice speaking and the
position of the Justice Department has
not been repealed and has not been
amended since the last decision on
October 16 2000 the President of the
United States this is getting way too
complicated and unnecessarily so you've
got a lot of second-tier slip-and-fall
lawyers all over TV spewing things they
don't know they don't understand the
Constitution they haven't studied the
cases I have first of all this opinion
says among other things that grand
juries and prosecutors cannot supplant
Congress they cannot supplant Congress
the only way to remove a sitting
president is through the impeachment
process not through the indictment
process they cannot disable or hamstring
a presidency which is what they're
trying to do as I speak a prosecutor
cannot trigger the twenty-fifth
amendment the twenty-fifth amendment is
that the purpose is not to be triggered
by a prosecutor and he can't step in and
try and take advantage of it these are
things that were discussed the president
cannot properly defend himself in
litigation under the Constitution as an
individual American when he has time
that he has to spend on official duties
unlike so many other individuals a
president the United States they point
out is so unique in our constitutional
system that it is enormous ly damaging
to him because he can't focus on his
defense which is different than civil
litigation and he can't focus during
that time on the nation's security and
well-being and the presidency can't
function properly with these kinds of
burdens this is what the memo says he
cannot be indicted as a sitting
president period this is why despite all
the pablum about what presidents have
received subpoenas before tummy named
one president who's ever been before a
federal grand jury there has never been
a president in front of a federal grand
jury ken starr's team subpoenaed Bill
Clinton we're having among other things
not sex so much with an intern in the
Oval Office but lying about litigation
that was taking place and he was
subpoena
and he decided to do a video so here's
my advice did the president the United
States who didn't seek it and to his
lawyers focus you're making this too
complicated the Constitution is on the
side of the President the Department of
Justice his own position which you can
brief yourselves is on the side of the
president's historical precedent is on
the side of the President of the United
States
legal precedent is on the side of the
president the United States stopped
listening to all the babbling the you
know pleading the faith and should he
sit down with a subpoena I would say if
I were the president's lawyer to mr.
Muller we want you to present us with an
explanation of your defiance of the
Department of Justice policy which you
are required to follow as a employee of
the Department of Justice moreover we
want to understand how it is that you
believe that you can burden a president
like this while he's in office and while
I'm at it Shawn
we seem to have a few Republicans in the
Senate who are very confused about these
things who have voted to protect mr.
Muller rather than protect the office of
the presidency the Constitution the and
the American people and they seem to
think that they have the power even
though they we have separation of powers
to tell a president who we can hire and
who we can fire the part of the problem
the president has is he's dealing with
ignoramus both inside his party and
outside his party and some of whom are
dressed up as lawyers so I would take
this all the way to the United States
Supreme Court I would make Muller and
his band of Democrat prosecutors make
their case all the way to the United
States Supreme Court if they try to
subpoena him in any way to appear before
a federal grand jury and make them make
their case against their own department
of justice against Supreme Court
precedent and against the Constitution
of the United States and if it takes six
months it takes six months if it takes
six years then by god it takes six years
we're not just talking about the
president which would be enough we're
talking about protecting the office of
the presidency separation of powers and
when you look at those 49 areas of
questions there's not a single criminal
statute there's not a single obstruction
what has
obstructed they're not investigating
Russia what is it that they're not
investigating that they don't want to
investigate no they want to know his
intent on whether he obstructed they
want to they want to treat him like they
treated Martha Stewart well guess what
he's the president mr. Muller this isn't
one of your failed anthrax cases or one
of your failed whitey bordering cases
this is the president the United States
you know what that means we the people
have a stake in this we the people get
to decide the framers decided the only
way you remove a president is through
the body politic through the house and
the Senate and it's a heavy burden not
by some rogue prosecutor with a bunch of
Democrat prosecutors they don't get to
do it and the people need to rise up and
demand demand that this go all the way
to the Supreme Court to put these rogue
prosecutors in their place that's why I
call you the great one this abusively
politically biased and frankly ethically
challenged Mullard team there's the
answer mark levin every Sunday night
10:00 Eastern Life Liberty and Levin
thank you sir